wow wirklich sehr toll dass ihr wieder
eingeschaltet habe es ist eine neue
folge allerdings denkt heute mit dem
momentan vom gewitter im kopf
nein natürlich nicht
es ist mir eine freude ihn begrüßen zu
dürfen geht ihr auf eine seite dann
holen wir uns auch schon den moderator
der ich bin der moderator da kommen doch
mal rein
es ist endlich wieder soweit alle gegend
afe die show auf der ems kanal in denen
ihr habt es euch so lange gewünscht so
lange gewartet und endlich sind wir
wieder da freunde ja sehr gut hat es
auch mal wieder gesagt du bist ja wir
haben heute nicht einen nicht zwei nicht
drei sondern vier kategorien vorbereitet
in denen die auf vier leute die beiden
kategorie beiden in denen die beiden in
der die beiden parteien gegeneinander
antreten werden die haben ein zweierteam
zum aller ersten mal in der geschichte
von alle gegen dave denn ihr seid
einfach unzertrennlich was sagst du dazu
das ist mal was anderes bestimmt oder
dort sehr gut unsere kategorie
gewinnseitig hasse dich dafür dass du
mich hasst warten lassen
die erste aufgabe der stellen müsst ist
alter schätzen ich sage euch ein bild
überlegt euch ab wie alt die person ist
und teilt es mir mit weil ich die zeit
rein das ist die erste kandidatin
erkennt ihr sie wer weiß wer es atemlos
über mich hinweg gerate durch kurz hier
erzählen und er hat hier zu sehen 32 1
10 4 und 5 sind 55 und 45 14 sie ist 35
ich glaube wenn sie zu sie ist jetzt
nicht sehr froh dass wahrscheinlich
automatisch ein bisschen wegen der
branche in der serie noch mal ich hab
gedacht ich hätte schon vorlauf gehört
dass sie für die alte ausnahmsweise das
5 sekunden ich wollte nur mit drin
nein
die nächste person aber ist ja eine
person ist
wer kennt ihn jayden james mit der sohn
von wismar dann überlegt euch mal wir
wollten konnten wir mal beraten
du hast du dann verschreiben nein
wirklich die zucchini liegt eigentlich
mit der andere und ich dachte du machst
mit andere sachen 3 23 21 19 und 21 er
ist 21 jahre alt ist übrigens wissen ich
habe bis dato noch nie in folge gewonnen
also ich hab bis dato zwei folgen
gewonnen selbst hat immer so geschnitten
dass wir dann doch würde ich persönlich
hätte 12 bis 13
aber meine meinung zählt hier nicht ok
hat sich beraten 33 14 15 und 64 okay
ihr habt mit 867 476 er aber bei dir ja
töricht gut vorstellen dass das so weiß
das ist mein vater auch wieder okay wir
machen natürlich weiter okidoki was wir
machen
okidoki die 32 es ist katja
30 kam es anders ja und da braucht es
gar nicht stimmt was wir dass gerade ich
würde sagen dass ich 32 23 bei 23 grad
es ist rein lasst uns sicherlich gab es
definitiv ist ok dann lasst und geht
jetzt komplett
das ist dein gescheut kannst du nicht
mit den dingen umgehen es ist einfach
auch hier die regel wie die beste person
in der canary vogel sehr gut die sieht
aus wie tims mutter ende fand eine
bewegung einen verein seitdem breit war
wirklich toll
hat er sie schon ein exempel groß
eigentlich wiederholen damit ein vater
gelernt aber stets genannt wenn nicht
tut es jetzt gib mir doch mal ein
tröpfchen von bilden dann machst leute
schilder wieder eingeschaltet haben wir
gucken uns jetzt an wie alt der
unglaubliche hulk hogan sind drei bei
167 3 und sinnt er ist 66 dave hat schon
wieder angekommen
aber was technisch war hat keinen punkt
bekommen denn ihr habt mir vollkommen
herzen glück wurden keine personen mehr
das heißt wir schlittern auch schon ins
nächste format als nächstes raten wir
nämlich preise von artikeln die jeder
kennt und liebt zum beispiel im
maschinenbau 38 somat spülmaschinen tabs
nicht schlecht der 30
ich arbeite ja das hat nicht auf den
preis geachtet das ist gut ich bin
youtuber ich kann es mir leisten habe
bei dem über 30 tausend abonnenten gehe
ich nicht mehr selber einkaufen deswegen
überlegt mal 38 maschinen tab format
gibt es auch mit bill gross denkt so
dass milch und liter milch fünf möglich
also warum kannst du mich abmelde mit
einbeziehen denn dass ihr hier seid
davis hat leider viele leute langsam
gehen mir aus abonniert war bitte bei
day damit er mich vielleicht genauso
unterstützen können das mit neuen anzug
und nissen pajun link wo wir max
nächsten an zuzahlungen halten was mir
nicht ok chef 21 53 wollte wir haben 50
angebot auf dem mittelmeer person und
jahr 50
du hast den euro gesorgt
es ist eure wenn du verlierst und sieben
euro sagen okay selbst du sieben euro
japan bleibt und jetzt über ein 31 31 95
reduziert sie kommen von vier jahren und
17 schlag jetzt zu läuten
kommen wir zum nächsten produkt handelt
sich um ein produkt das wirklich fast
jeder kennt und liebt
thieme ist disqualifiziert
du bist jetzt allein in deinem etwas
dazu sagen dass ich habe gerade gesehen
22 12 93 32 und 49 99 sind 43 99
der punkt geht auch wieder du bist
scheinbar ein echter ja ich hab's mir
rein mit dem trichter ein echter
shopping experten dass gerade der
klägliche versuch irgendwas in diesem
video
der nächste artikel und dieser ist
wirklich sehr vernehmlich muss mich
dafür entschuldigen aber ich weiß nicht
was ich mir dabei gedacht hat einfach so
eine fahrrad bräuchte die typische
klientel ehrenfelder 45 jahre midlife
crisis noch einmal kam pech hinzu disc
erscheint es auch gerne bei 393 340 600
sind 201 und vielleicht ist es auch ein
kindertag ist dass die real seite
nächstes ich denke ja ich dachte ich das
ist so ein discounter mehr wodurch die
36 lachen dass ich hab jetzt keine mehr
ist radfahren steht vielen unentschieden
7 4 unentschieden beim anlegen wollen
ich will wieder zurück der moderator
dieser folge david hinrichs direkt
fahren direkt alle absolventen bleibt
doch nicht weggelaufen ich stecke mir
direkt in die fragen hätten wir kommen
zum helden wer glaube damit kannst du
jetzt sehr gut seien gegen ein bisschen
um geografie das gute ist dass ich mich
als teilnehmer vor der kamera stehe weil
wenn ich spielen will braucht hier hätte
ich so was von verpackt aber ich konnte
nichts mit der hilfe des internets
vorbereitet und deshalb frage ich euch
wie weit ist es von hier nach brüssel ja
denn die tester in diesen tagen die ich
mit 32 33 110 130 ja es sind 181 heft
aber wir reden
das habe ich gleich gesagt drehen von
luft liege aber das war wirklich davon
haben was sie ausgegangen also das hätte
sich wirklich jeder den können ich sehe
überhaupt keinen fehler meinerseits wir
machen weiter mit der nächsten entfernen
und zwar kartenhaus kam aus nach dresden
und taxis in diesem fall müssten höhere
zusagen dann wird's gut wenn dies wie
weit ist es das erste mal dass wir so
nah beieinander sein und ich weiß zu
berichten dass es nur einen sieger gibt
und dieser sieger
[Musik]
jan ist es denn es sind 368 km und die
nächste frage wie weit ist die
entfernung luftlinie von mailand nach
nach polit
pablo espanyol 317 monat 400 und 700
eine person ist nicht weit weg von der
richtigen antwort und diese person ist
ja denn es sind 657 ja wenn wir schon
bei den sendern entfernungen sind dann
sagt mir mal bitte wie weit bitte nicht
zu ja lieber nicht ich würde lieber
fragen wie weit ist es von toronto nach
melbourne
würde jemand dran derjenige ist ja es
sind 600 immer noch tut mir wirklich
leid beim nächsten mal würde ich einfach
gar nicht mehr einschalten
altbekannte disziplin ich habe hier
meine waage wofür wird sie normalerweise
benutzt gibt mal einen tipp ab hier
willst es nicht zum umrühren
katz vom sega zu wiegen die anlage zu
wiegen das ist wirklich eine sehr
experimentelle antwort habe ich auch mal
mit drin sein werde ich dir leider weiß
ich glaube das würde die zuschauer
ich glaube ich möchte jetzt einfach
laufen das ist normales verhalten ist
dass man sich den größeren teil der
gruppe zu wenden ich möchte mich
irgendwie entschuldigen gegenstände
geben zum beispiel mercedes schluessel
der gehört mir
ich habe mercedes und jede schätzen wie
schwer ist dieses objekt der begierde
okay aber 1000 kino noch etwas
ausführung okay aber ich glaube
sebastian gefährt mit dem auto deshalb
ist es ja ihr habt eure schätzung euch
überlegt dave du bist das nicht so dran
und dann werden wir auch schon gucken
wie schwer das objekt der begierde ist
wie ich erst meinen abend ja das war
glaube ich zu viel für die feiertage 32
17 90 79 10 8 504 kosmehl
ich darf hier für 500 gramm pasta
gehamstert
der rat am 16 das gewicht von unter die
decke 35 mich war ständig auf 50 87 96
es sind tatsächlich möglich 18 gewiss
sagen das ist ungefähr 13 kilo
die batterie sollte stinknormal also das
glücklich stinknormal aaa batterie 321
18 24 und 18 71 87 es sind in
wirklichkeit 22,8 das heißt der punkt
geht machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
zeit bezahlen es handelt sich diesmal
david probiere mich ein bisschen zu euch
ich muss euch jetzt solidarischer weise
auch mal kurz ausschließen wir kommen im
nächsten aufgabe es handelt sich dabei
um nichts geringeres als ich gebe auch
meine schätzung habe 1,73 weil 126 safe
ist damit näher dran
sogar als ich der game hass der gamer
ist er dankbar dass wir wieder verlassen
das 1 kommentar wir sehen uns ja das hat
spaß gemacht macht's gut